jim avignon nennt er sich seite einmal
völlig pleite in der gleichnamigen
südfranzösischen stadt strandete und
begann mit malen seinen lebensunterhalt
zu verdienen
100 großformatige bilder pro woche
produziert in berlin locker
schnelligkeit ist ein zentrales motiv
seiner kunst
hallo willkommen in meinem studio
renommierte galeristen verzweifeln an
jim avignon weil er seine werke so
günstig verkauft
er will die regeln des kunstmarkt
unterlaufen und zählt auch zu den
wichtigsten vertretern der chip art ich
hab mir eine person skizziert deren
motivation absichten bildhaft aus dem
kopf heraus treten dann werde ich das
ganze kolorieren spitze steht
in den knalligen und vermeintlich
fröhlichen bildern das mittvierziger
steckt auch immer ein funke
gesellschaftskritik ich arbeite mit
acrylfarben
die sind wasserlöslich werden später
wasserfest trocken sehr schnell
generell bin ich dafür bekannt dass ich
sehr viel mit den primärfarben arbeite
so rot gelb blau
meistens beginnt mit einer dieser farben
um schon mal eine grund grunde
farbstimmung wie festzulegen
manchmal hatte ich aber verwehrt und
tatsächlich danach ob einfach noch farbe
übliches die vermalt werden soll
also ich bin ein sehr eigenartig sparsam
umgehen der mensch mit farben bei mir
wird jeder rest vermalt und auch wenn es
dem bild vielleicht gar nicht besser tut
noch eine farbe drauf zu bekommen
insofern die die erste entscheidung ist
einfach eine eigene farbe mit der man
gut weiterarbeiten kann die als basis
gut dient und es kann auch sein das
thema wieder komplett um gemalt hat die
erste
ich male auf den boden weil ich meine
farben meistens sehr verdünne damit in
höhe von euch kraft haben
wenn ich das in der wand machen würde
würde das einfach alles immer nur
ständig herunter laufen meistens arbeite
ich nur mit den grundfarben und mich mir
die auf der leinwand oder auf dem papier
selber an genau ich male nicht auf
leinwand
es hat den hauptgrund dass ich diese
bilder dann auch zusammen falten kann
mit 30 stück doch im koffer problemlos
um wind fliegen kann der ausstellung
machen 30 leinwänden der größe müsste
ich eine spedition beauftragen
nachdem ich die ganzen farben
aufgetragen hat kommt noch mal eine
phase in der ich die nach ziehe auch
noch mal durch die dicke des strichs
betonung setzte man die strecke auch
nicht mehr nachts ist das einfach nur
noch die übermalte linie zu sehen ist
dann manche den schatten doch mal nach
mal dadurch versuche ich nochmal dem
bild und stärkeren aus ton charakter zu
geben und ich glaube ich bin schon auch
sehr stark zeichner insofern ist für
mich einfach der zeichnerische
parodierend dass die konstruktion aus
linien das zusammenspiel der linien
werde wesentliche kompositorische
gestaltungselement beim malen ich mal
seit 25 jahren beruflich wird immer
wieder kritisiert dass ich meinen stil
in dieser zeit eigentlich fast überhaupt
nicht verändert hat
ich sehe mich aber selber eher wie einen
geschichtenerzähler und ich bin nicht
der künstler der denk ich muss jetzt
wieder komplett neue richtung arbeiten
was neues erforschen
da geht es mir wirklich viel mehr um die
inhalte also ich arbeite konstant an den
inhalten weiter aber die bildsprache es
für mich so wie sie es perfekt bleibt
sie auch
mit diesem bild bin ich tatsächlich
sogar ziemlich zufrieden angesichts der
doch sehr komprimierten zeit die dafür
zur verfügung stand der gesichtsausdruck
von dem typen bis schon sehr nah dran
nicht mir vorgestellt habe und auch
farblich von der vom bild auf vorher
denke ich ist eine ganz okay
konstruktion schande war das endgültige
urteil kann ich erst ein paar monaten